- [Voiceover] Yeah,
every guitar has a story.
(heavy guitar music)
(soft guitar music)
- My name is Rick Kelly.
I custom-make guitars here
at Carmine Street Guitars.
I make guitars from reclaimed lumber,
old New York City building wood
and from 200 year old trees.
Most of the wood is being thrown away
and so I just dumpster dive for it.
The craft of it is one
of my favorite things.
You know, building from the
materials that are historic
and coming up with
instruments that make music
and are kind of alive in a different way.
It's a lot of, you know, steps involved.
(lively guitar music)
I bring the wood here and
then I have to de-nail it
and then surface it and cut
it to shape on the band saw,
sand it smooth, and then I
use mostly shellac finishes,
which is a natural finish.
A lot of people have come
through Carmine Street Guitars
and bought my custom
guitars over the years.
Bob Dylan, Lou Reed, Patti
Smith band, Roger Waters,
Steely Dan band, so many other bands.
(acoustic guitar music)
To be able to give life
back into the instrument
from the old timbers that built this city
is a wonderful feeling.
To be able to make it have a new life
and turn into something that makes music.
It's wonderful.